hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel today I'm finally going to be
showing you my current gaming setup now
I want to preface this video by saying
that I currently live in a really really
really small space so while I am you
know pretty proud of the stuff that I
managed to get working Han I was also
hoping this video might be helpful for
maybe people who were living at home and
have to have that setup in that bedroom
maybe people who are even living in a
dome because I live in a studio
apartment so I only have one room and it
is very small but I do have all the
current consoles and some older ones so
I'm going to be showing you guys those
might be ah set up so let's get to it
starting with the chair I'm on right now
[Music]
this is a bad idea gaming SLO 5000 black
and white obviously and I really really
like it I was looking at different
gaming chests for a pretty long time of
course this is something that I need to
accommodate the space time in you guys
can see I'm very close to my bed where
this is situated but it isn't
comfortable there's a cushion right here
behind your head and also one that sits
on your lower back which is probably my
favorite and I can also do this fun
thing goodbye I definitely almost nearly
fell over it was just very good so
before I go full woods and show you guys
the rest with stuff I'm gonna go behind
me real quick and show you my Elgato
green screen which this is how easy this
thing is to set up it's a great system
great product I have a separate video up
about that on my channel already so now
it's desk time so first things first
here we have my mouse which is a Razer
Naga epic chroma it's a wireless that
you can plug it in and I do mostly play
with it plugged in I just leave it on my
desk
unplugged swapping over to my phone real
quick to shoot POV of my desk hot my
keyboard is also a Raisa
is a Black Widow ultimate very
mechanical keyboard I've had it since I
think 2013 it's still going strong big
fan of to come up these two even though
this is a chroma this is not so this
doesn't light up with that I do have a
different keyboard that does but this
one's my favorite
of all of my keyboards and then of
course I need to show you
my mouse pad which I love this is a pop
G mouse pad I think this is just so cool
so then we have my desk drawer which has
PlayStation controller xbox controller
there a couple of spares back here
that's my TV remote I've got my DS and
of course this for the switch as well
which I almost never use but it is handy
to have it all there and now to the
actual setup so consoles of course we
have my xbox 1x sitting in there my
Nintendo switch slaughtered in there my
ps4 and that's just cable obviously
they're not in any particular order or
anything like that just slot it into one
of the holes in the cube this is my PC
so my PC is a cyber PowerPC the model is
via can es-100
it's pretty small most oh my favorite
things about it so it's actually really
like easy to move around processor it's
got an Intel Core i5 at 6600 K at 3.5
gigahertz my graphics card is an AMD
Radeon on 9 390 X 8 gigabyte and I've
got 16 gigs of ram meaning I can run
pretty much everything everything on
oculus runs great
are you do a deeper dive into a video
just about my PC if you guys want to
know more about that this is really just
supposed to be setup stuff but I do
really like it sometimes I've had to
take it to work so it's it's convenient
but I also have my Elgato Game Capture
Kia and just an Astra headset here with
CF Eve's name on the side I gotta have a
proper stand for this but it does
actually stand kind of nicely by itself
so sit right there down on the bottom on
this side a very neatly still packaged I
always put them back is my oculus touch
setup with controllers and my oculus
unit itself now I know this probably
seems a little bit insane but it's just
easier for me in this space to set these
up I usually put the cameras there and
there and just set it up individually
every time I use it it really doesn't
take that long I don't have any major
issues with doing that this final little
cubby hole down here has my glorious
incredibly dusty and 64 which I actually
haven't used in a long time is one
controller back here and I do also have
my B which is almost equally dusty but
it is nice having this kind of like
old-school Nintendo shelf I've got a
couple more controllers like my pro
controller and tons of games for both of
those my TV I don't know anything about
it it sucks it's 1080 it's nothing
special hoping to upgrade to a better
monitor soon right now we actually have
a multi HD input so that I can actually
jump between all of my consoles and a
converter for my 64 as well but that is
the gist of it and the thing about my
setup in you guys is that it is in a
wardrobe so I've actually closed it now
so when I don't want people to see it I
can just hide it behind the mirrors and
that's how that works that is my bed you
can see right behind me I wasn't kidding
when I said this apartment was really
small ok I do have more collectibles and
all my games and everything are in a
bookcase I've got some swords and well I
actually do have a lot of more cool
stuff in here but this was just supposed
to be a gaming setup video if you guys
want to see me do like a collectables
wrath stuff to it I could do that to
kind of elaborate on that more if you
would like but that's it for me today
everyone I hope you guys
interesting I'm very happy with the
setup I have here again especially
considering the tiny space that I have
the fact that I even managed to fit a
desk in this apartment is a miracle we
make it work like literally that's my
bed you can that's my bed right there
but I'm happy with it that's the main
thing so thank you guys all so much for
watching huge thanks to everyone's names
on screen right now and I'll see you
guys and next time Oh